HYUNYOUNG SONG:
Hello, everybody.
Welcome to our session, Innovate
with the Glass Platform.
My name is Hyunyoung Song.
I also go by HY.
PY LALIGAND: And my name
is Pierre-Yves Laligand,
but I go by PY.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: We're Google
Glass software engineers.
Today, we're going to
first talk about some
of the big changes that happened
to our platform, one of which
is the GDK, short for
Glass Development Kit.
And then we're going to talk a
little bit about what changes
we made to the Android
to enable GDK to explore
the wearable form
factor of glass
so that developers can take
advantage of our platform.
Lastly, we're going to
show you two demos that
highlight some of the GDK
API and Android API on Glass.
Around last November, we
released the GDK to the public,
and as of this year, April,
GDK entered the Preview mode,
which means that Glassware
that was built using GDK
can now be submitted to
be listed on our Buy Glass
website.
GDK is a supplementary library
that you can use in addition
to Android SDK to
build GDK Glassware.
We wanted to upgrade our
platform so that everybody
can use the latest Android API.
Last year, when I was
giving a similar talk,
our platform was based on Ice
Cream Sandwich 4.0.4, API level
15.
But as of this year,
April, our platform
is based on KitKat 4.4.2 API 19.
This upgrade brought
a new set of APIs
available on Glass,
some of which
will be showcased later on
during this talk during PY's
and my demo.
SDK Manager, inside IDE such
as Eclipse, Android Studio,
allow you to seamlessly
download the GDK Jar
so that you can create
your GDK Glassware.
Along with it comes some
sample apps that you can also
download to use as a template
to write your own GDK Glassware.
As a matter of fact, a lot
of the screenshots and videos
that you're going to see
later on in this talk
are captured from
these sample apps.
For those of you who have
not checked out the GDK yet,
this is the web URL.
And for developers who
already have a Glass and who
have a GDK-based
Glassware, the first link
lists all of the
checklists that you
should check before
your submission-- oh,
the checklist is the second one.
The first one is the
form itself where
you submit your GDK Glassware.
Enough with the announcement.
Let's talk about GDK
from a high level.
One of the first things
that you can do with GDK
is make your Glassware
integrate with the timeline.
If you use the
voice trigger API,
you can start your Glassware
from our clock screen,
using either voice
or the touch pad.
Using the LiveCard API, you
can draw into the timeline
to the left of the clock screen.
In this example, our
compass sample app
is drawing the user's
orientation into the timeline.
But if you do not
want to use LiveCard
and do not want to
draw into the timeline,
you can use CardScrollView
to create your own view
or set of views
in Immersive mode
so that it has
exactly the same swipe
and flinging behavior,
just like the timeline
and Glassware system apps.
To create cards that goes
inside the CardScrollView that
looks exactly a similar way
as the Glass system apps,
you can use the Card API.
This API is not public yet.
It'll end this API demo.
This will be rolled
out to you at the next
or the following upcoming OTA.
Contextual Voice
Menu API will allow
you to enable the voice
flow within your own app,
just like how we support the
voice flow from our clock
screen.
GestureDetector
API is the one that
is optimized to work
best on Glass touch pad.
As a matter of fact,
this is the API
that is used within
our Glass system apps,
and also some of our
framework services.
If you want exactly the same
touch behavior as the system
apps, this is the API
that will come in handy.
There are some
APIs that allow you
to listen to the state
changes within Glass.
On-head detection is
a framework feature
that uses the sensor
facing towards your eye
so that the Glass will
know whether you're wearing
your device or where
you took it off.
This feature is used to
optimize the state of Glass.
For example, if you're
not wearing the device,
then it turns off some of the
services that doesn't really
have to run to conserve power.
There is a API
within-- this intent
API, which is part of GDK,
is fired whenever they're
on the transition edge so
that third party apps can also
listen to it so that
they can turn off
some of the services that
doesn't necessarily have to run
when the user is not
wearing the device.
There's more to the
GDK, but everybody
can read it on the website.
What I'm going to talk right now
is what are some of the changes
that we've made to the
Android to enable GDK.
This is a rough sketch of
what the typical Android
vertical stack looks like.
On top of Linux Kernel
runs the Dalvik runtime,
native libraries.
On top of it is the
framework, which
is a set of services
that support
the Android SDK and
applications sit top of it.
These are some of
the commands that you
can execute to inspect each
one of these vertical layers
on both your Glass device
and on your mobile phone.
As a matter of fact,
this is the command
that I executed
when I first joined
Glass to see what was there.
If you execute these, instead
of the Android default launcher,
inside Glass platform, there
is Glass something APKs
that represent the
various features that
are already available in Glass.
In particular, GlassHome is
our version of the launcher
that lets you insert your
own Glassware into our clock
screen, and also the one
that renders the timeline.
Boutique is the APK
that downloads Glassware
that you turned on
the My Glass website.
When you execute the
dumpsys-l command,
you also see all of the standard
Android services, activity,
window, power,
battery, and so forth.
Two that we did
change in our Glass
are the location and
the account service.
Because compared
to default standard
Android where everything
is done on the client,
Glass does authentication
using the My Glass website.
The GPS information is
piped through your companion
app for better accuracy.
There are some services
that we inserted.
HeadGesture service
monitors when
you are moving your head around,
so that when you look up,
that screen turns on.
The EyeGesture is
what I just talked
about when I was describing
on-head detection card that
monitors the movement of
your eye, that also enables
Wink Feature for wink
to photo feature.
And lastly, this
timeline manager
is the service that
runs in the background
so that you can draw
into the timeline
from your remote Glassware
app using the LiveCard API.
For the rest, we changed a
little bit of native libraries,
we changed a little
bit of kernel,
but we didn't touch Dalvik
virtual machine at all.
All in all, we
didn't touch any part
that a vendor building
a mobile phone or tablet
would have kept untouched.
At this point, I would like
a quick show of hands--
how many of you
sitting in the audience
have modified Android OSP?
How many of you are
Android developers?
Now, PY is going to further
your understanding of what
we did on Glass platform.
PY LALIGAND: Thank you, HY.
I wanted to give you a
little more perspective
on all the work we've
done on Android.
The graph you see here
shows the relative size
of the Android SDK
versus the GDK.
And as you can see, the former
really dwarfs the latter.
I think that illustrates
very well what
we're trying to achieve
with the GDK, which
is we're trying to build a
complement to the Android SDK,
so that you guys can continue
building on a platform
that you know and hopefully
love while at the same time
taking advantage of what makes
Glass such a specific device.
A lot of it has to do
with user interaction.
And as you can see, by
comparing the first two columns,
UI widgets make for a very
small part of the SDK.
To replace those, we've added
our own widgets to the GDK,
but you can still very
much take advantage
of the vast majority
of the Android SDK.
Under the hood, same story.
We haven't added all that
much to the system server,
just enough to
support the services
that HY talked about earlier.
All in all, at its
core, Glass is very much
a standard Android device.
We really believe in the
potential of this platform,
and especially for
wearable devices.
Under the circumstances,
what does it really
mean to innovate on Glass?
First, I'd like to take a very
short trip down memory lane.
Not long ago, the
rise of mobile devices
has opened up a lot
of new opportunities--
touch screens, mobile
data, sensors for location,
acceleration, sound, paved
the way for new experiences
that were previously unfeasible
on older computing platforms.
Well, we think
that a similar wave
is coming with her
wearable devices,
with Glass at its forefront.
It's very important
to understand
what makes those
devices different.
In the case of
Glass, the location
of the device on the
user's head greatly
reduces the amount of time
between user intent and action.
Likewise, the ability
of a heads-up display
makes it so that you can very
quickly serve information
to the user.
All in all, of the
hands-free features,
such as voice recognition,
eye gesture, hand gestures,
enable the use of the
device in situations
that require the user's full
attention and full skills.
But that's not all
there is to Glass.
As you can see on
this slide, there's
a wealth of features packed in
this small and light device.
You could just as
well take advantage
of the BCT, that's
the Bone Conducting
Transducer, the little speaker
in the back of the frame,
to notify the user
instantly without even
turning the screen on.
Or you could re-purpose of the
button at the top of the frame
to let the user give your app
a very clear and fast signal.
I think there lies one of the
big principles for designing
and innovating
with Glass-- really
understand what makes the
device different-- its form
factor and all its
components-- and learn
to use all these features
and combine them smartly
using all the platform APIs.
This is very important,
not only to create
new, compelling
experiences, but also
to overcome some of the
challenges that inevitably
come with new devices.
And to illustrate
that last point,
I'd like to walk you
through an example that's
taken straight out
of your devices.
I'd like to talk to
you about web browser.
With a mobile
device, a touchscreen
makes it very easy to
interact with the web.
You can directly
manipulate the content.
It feels very natural.
Unless, of course, no
touchscreen, no such luck.
But still, web browsing
is very important to us
in the context of search.
So unless you can perform
a search by saying,
OK, Glass, search, and
then your search query.
Sometimes, you get the result
whose snippet is good enough,
but you need to dig
a little deeper.
And that's where the web
browser comes into play.
The first thing we
did is actually really
focus on that use case
and get rid of things
like tab browsing,
bookmarks, et cetera.
It so happens that really
narrowing down your use cases
is about 50% of the work.
For the remaining 50%, let
me show you what we did.
The context is you just
run a search query,
you have the result
snippet, you tap twice
to actually open the link, and
you're directed to a web page.
At this point, if you put
two fingers on the touch pad,
you're entering browse mode,
whereby moving your head
around will pan around the page.
Sliding the fingers up
and down the touch pad
will control the zoom level.
If you let go of the
two fingers and you're
centered on the link,
you're just two steps away
from actually
navigating that link.
So there it is--
getting to a page,
navigating, finding
some information,
and optionally following a link.
That's exactly
what we want to do.
It turns out the
experience-- I invite
you to try it-- is pretty cool.
It works well.
Now I'd like to show you
how we could build this,
if we were to replicate it.
The first thing
you need to do is
to monitor the
movement of the head.
This is done through a standard
Android SDK API, the sensor
manager.
You want to get a hold of
the rotation vector sensor
and register for updates,
so that's the first snippet.
And as you can see,
in the second snippet,
whenever the orientation of the
device, and so of the user's
head, changes, you get an update
with three angles describing
the position of the device.
That's how you would track
the user's movements.
The second step is the
touch pad interaction.
For this, we created
an API and a GDK,
as HY mentioned, the
Gesture Detector.
First, you want to add
a finger listener, which
will allow you to get in
and out of Browse mode,
depending on the
number of fingers
that land on the touch pad.
The second step is to
install a scroll listener,
so that if you so happen
to be in Browse mode,
you just control the zoom
level based on the delta.
Very simple.
There's one last
thing, too-- you
need to pass touch events
to this gesture detector,
and that's done by overriding
this method in your activity
and just passing the
events to the detector.
Very simple.
What we've seen is
a way to combine
some of Glass' very
unique features
together to overcome
a challenge that
is really specific to Glass.
We've used a mixture of Android
APIs-- Activity SensorManager--
as well as GDK APIs,
the GestureDetector.
I think we've talked
enough right now,
and it's time for some demos.
Just one thing,
though-- this session
is meant to be very
technical, and we're
going to be showing more code.
But if you're more
interested in the design
aspects of innovating on Glass,
I invite you to check out
the talk that happened yesterday
called Design for Wearables,
I think.
It will probably online
very soon, if not already.
For our first demo, you'll
find it's very topical.
You might have heard of this
little sporting event that's
grabbing the attention of about
half of the planet these days,
and that's the FIFA World Cup.
If you so happen to be among
the other half of the planet,
that's soccer we're
talking about.
It so happens that
on the Glass team,
we have a lot of
avid soccer fans.
And recently, a device has
grabbed our attention, too.
This is the Adidas
miCoach Smart Ball.
This is Adidas' latest entry in
their line of personal coaching
devices.
This is not your
average soccer ball.
It packs a lot of
sensors to give you
feedback on your
dead ball kicks,
so that you can understand
and ultimately improve
your technique.
We've got a couple of these
balls, and we had a lot of fun
at practice competing over who
can kick the ball the hardest.
I finished second.
But very soon, the engineering
code started spinning,
and realized, how
cool would this
be to actually integrate
this with Glass
for a totally
hands-free experience,
like not having to carry a phone
or a tablet to get the results?
We met with a couple
of Adidas engineers.
We brainstormed for awhile.
We decided to build
a quick prototype
over the course of
not even a week.
Let me show you what we did.
First, we're going to switch
to a little program called
ScreenCast that we showed
last year that will allow
me to share with you what I'm
seeing on my Glass device.
Let me try unplugging
and replugging it.
The old recipes.
Oh, yeah.
We have two devices.
That may be why.
This is how you would use AGB,
in case you're not familiar.
You can use it over Wi-Fi.
We're trying to use
it over this cable.
It's not working so well.
Fingers crossed.
Yay.
This is the demo.
No, I'm kidding.
All right, so the first
step, what I'm going to do
is actually start the app.
OK, Glass?
Start practicing.
And so what this
does is it actually
tries to connect to the
ball using Bluetooth LE.
That's an API that
became available on Glass
with the XE16 update.
It looks like we're connected.
That's truly a miracle.
All right.
We're ready.
How about we take a kick?
No?
All right.
I'll do it.
I just have to tap
and I'm ready to kick.
All right, let's see how I did.
Now, basically what
the app is doing,
it's communicating with the
ball to fetch some data.
If you used this ball with the
provided app, what it does,
it gives you feedback
on your speed,
your point of impact on the
ball, the trajectory, launch
angle, rotation, a lot
of very useful data.
We'll see if worked
in that case.
Oh my god, yeah,
it was a lame kick.
[LAUGHTER]
PY LALIGAND: So as
I mentioned, this
was something we built
in a couple of days.
Especially the mathematics
part is not that solid.
It really needs a clean
trajectory to work.
Unfortunately, the stage
is a little too small.
But fortunately,
what we did is we
built a demo mode
inside the demo.
Let's try it again.
Start.
That was a kick.
Let's see how it does.
Hopefully it won't be as
lame as the previous one.
Takes a little while,
because it's pretty slow.
Oh my god, it's
51 miles per hour.
So I have immediate
feedback, and I
can keep going, just
trying another kick,
and all the results
will accumulate
so I can keep track of
my performance so far.
That's pretty much it.
Very simple demo.
Let's go back to the slide.
So again--
[APPLAUSE]
PY LALIGAND: So again,
I wanted to walk you
through how you would go about
building something like this.
And reading this
slide, I realize
I forgot a part of the demo,
which is-- so you know,
it's fine to start a kick
by tapping the touch pad,
but when you're at
practice, you've
have been running for awhile,
you're sweaty and everything,
you don't want to have to reach
for a touch pad at every turn.
What we did is we just hacked
the wink feature so that you
could actually start
kicking every time you wink,
and that's pretty cool.
I wish I had been in on that.
Anyway, moving on.
Let's see how we built
that under the hood.
The first API we used-- I
won't go into too much details,
because that's a very well
documented GDK API which allows
you to add an entry into
the voice menu, like HY
showed you earlier.
It's manifest-based, just
like the launcher API.
Very simple.
You can check out
documentation for this.
Second step is to connect
to a Bluetooth LE device.
This is done through the
standard Bluetooth Manager
Android API.
The first step is to
actually discover devices.
That's the purpose of the
start LE scan method there.
It takes an optional
argument, which
is a list of services
you might use
if you want to filter devices.
But it turns out it's
a bit buggy in 4.4.2,
but there are other
ways to work around
this that are fairly well
documented on the web.
You're searching for
devices and you found one.
Then, what you need
to do is actually
connect to that device.
That's the role
of the connect gap
method in the first snippet.
The third argument
is a call back
through which pretty
much everything
will flow from that point on.
This is a very asynchronous API.
You start connecting,
and then if you're lucky,
you get connected.
The next step is to
discover services,
so essentially
discover the API that's
available on the remote device.
And again, as I mentioned, this
is an asynchronous process,
and you get a call back.
Once you have discovered
services, what you need to do
is grab a hold of
characteristics.
Very simply, characteristics
are attributes
of the remote devices that
you can read and write,
and that's basically how you
interact with the device.
The second part
of the slide shows
how you read the
data, for example,
from a device [INAUDIBLE].
You just issue a read command,
and a little while later, you
get data back.
That's more of a pull model.
But the Bluetooth LE API
also has a push model
where you can
request notifications
to be sent to you on a
given characteristic,
so that's what this pretty
complicated first snippet
does for you.
And then later on, if
something like the state
of the remote device
changes, you get a call back,
and with the values
you're interested in.
For that particular demo,
we used the mix of both push
and pull, but that really
depends on the protocol
that this remote device
chose to implement.
Next up is showing some UIs.
We've seen examples
of that shown by HY.
The first API you want to
use is the CardScrollView.
This is a very
standard adapter view.
If you've ever used the likes
of ListView or GridView,
you'll feel right at home.
It's extremely similar.
It extends AdapterView,
essentially.
It'll give you this nice card
flipping and flinging behavior.
The second API we used to
create those nice little cards
is the Card API that
HY also talked about.
You can view that
as a View Builder.
You put your data
in there, and then
you request a view,
and all of a sudden,
you have this nice little
formatted view hierarchy.
I invite you to use
the two together
because we've optimized them,
memory wise and speed wise,
and they work quite
well together,
as you can see in
the last snippet that
shows how, in your adapter, you
can defer to your card object
and not have to worry about
things like recycling and such.
Lastly, how do we
intercept winks?
As you can see, this is
based on a broadcast intent.
The only thing you need to do is
register a Broadcast Receiver.
It's that simple.
However, there are two things
that you shouldn't miss.
The first one is
on the second line.
You want to set the priority
to a very, very high number
so that you have your object's
first shot at the event.
Because this broadcast
is an ordered broadcast.
The second thing is when
you receive the event,
and you've decided OK,
I'm going to handle it,
don't forget to actually
board the broadcast event,
otherwise it's going to get
passed around to other apps.
You'll probably end up
taking a picture which
is probably not what you want.
I now I would like to
direct your attention
to the little passive aggressive
message at the bottom right
of the slide that says
that this is a hack.
This is a very
experimental feature.
If you try to use it in an app
that you submit to My Glass,
I'm afraid you won't go
through the review process.
Sounds like we don't
want you to use it,
but it's still very
much a work in progress.
We have tons of work to
do on the detection side
to make it way more reliable.
The second part, also, is that
the API is not final at all.
Right now, we're using
broadcast intents,
but we have several
ideas to improve that.
We really don't want to pull
the rug from under your feet.
As a rule of thumb, if
you stick with the GDK,
you'll be in a good spot.
All right, so that's it for
the Adidas smart ball demo.
Again, making use of
several components of Glass
to provide that
experience, and again,
a mixture of both Android APIs,
BluetoothManagers, and such, as
well as GDK APIs, which
has CardScrollView, Card,
and whatnot.
Now we're going to show
you the second demo,
and it looks like HY is going
to have some explaining to do.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: The
second demo that I'm
going to show you
also showcases how
the hands-free nature
of Glass can improve
outdoor activities-- and
in this case, cycling,
that's back of my head
actually using this device.
For the longest
time, what I want
to have while cycling
was a rearview camera.
As of last December, we
started rolling out some kernel
features, and one of them OTG
mode-- that is, USB host mode.
We're trying to start
my demo as I speak.
Give me a second.
That was connected.
A miracle.
You're an amazing audience.
Everything's working.
And so what I did-- so what
I did is I got a webcam,
and then I connected
to my Glass device
so that I can see the video
stream on my Glass device.
Right now, we're using a
little bit different mode
than PY's demo,
because as you can see,
my USB port is taken
by my OTG cable.
We're doing our ADB over Wi-Fi.
We're not getting this screen.
PY LALIGAND: They
told us not to use
any wireless technology
for this demo.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: So yes, I
can actually see all of you
from the back of my head.
But this is really unfortunate.
Yes.
I think the 2.4 gigahertz Wi-Fi
spectrum is really maxed out.
This worked like five times.
Because doing the demo
with Wi-Fi has always
this trickiness, I did
record a video yesterday
using this device while I was
cycling through our Google
main campus.
This was recorded using
the Screen Record, which
was on another goodness
that we inherited
by upgrading to KitKat.
As you can see, I
am riding my bike,
and this is what I capture
from my rearview camera.
To demonstrate how easy it
is to switch between cameras,
this is the camera
feed that is coming
from the internal
camera, and yes, there's
a little bit of lag.
Then I'm going to switch to
my rearview camera again.
Using the Options menu and
then the second Options menu
is-- I can see a
shadow of myself riding
my bike over there with
the [INAUDIBLE] head.
A big disclaimer here
is that this I built
over the course of a week, and
this is really ugly and big,
and would have never seen
the light of a public camera
if this was not an engineer
or developing session,
but the idea is that I wanted to
show you that everybody in here
can make this themselves, too.
[APPLAUSE]
HYUNYOUNG SONG:
So what did I do?
What is exactly on
top of this helmet?
In an ideal world, all
you would really need
is a USB host
mode-enabled host device
and an OTG cable and
a low-power webcam.
But life is not that simple.
Most of the webcam
that you get from Frys
or your local electronics
store requires 500 milliamps
when Glass can only provide
300 milliamps on a host mode.
That's why I introduced
this USB hub.
This USB hub serves
two purposes.
First one, so that it
connects to the battery pack
to charge the webcam so that I
can record as long as possible.
The second important reason
is that the USB device driver
will not establish
the connection
if your peripheral
device says, oh, I
need more power than
what you can provide me.
This USB-powered hub
tells the Glass device,
I don't need any power from
you, and hence, the Glass
is OK with it, and then
establishes the connection.
Some of the commands that you
can execute yourself to verify
that everything has been
properly set up-- the first one
is LS USB.
it lists two additional
peripheral devices for my case,
because I have the USB
hub and also the webcam.
And if everything
worked correctly,
we also modified the camera
hardware abstraction layer
so that you don't have
to root your device.
All this change will be
part of your upcoming OTA.
If everything is
correctly mounted,
you'll see that video 0 node
mounted on the dev partition.
What you should look out for is
you should look at the kernel
logs.
If the kernel logs
say, oh, there's
insufficient power
available on this test,
then it means that that webcam
that you purchased that you
thought was a low-power is
not actually a low power one,
so get a new one,
or get a USB hub.
The beauty of the Glassware
that I built over the week
is that it's less than
300 lines of Java code.
Because the webcam
can be accessed
using standard
Android camera API.
That gets a number of cameras'
method-- it'll return two.
Camera index 0 will be
the internal camera,
and 1 will be the webcam.
And after you said
proper size and frames
per second and pixel
format, and then attach
a SurfaceHolder to
it, you can start
a preview, which is
what you just saw.
The direct rendering
callback that you're
going to attack to
the LiveCard, it
is a subclass of the
SurfaceHolder callback.
It has one specific
Glass callback method,
which is rendering paused.
This is what partially
what made this demo work is
that this response to
the visibility state
of the LiveCards.
When LiveCard is
no longer visible,
that paused boolean
variable returned true.
At that point, release
the expensive resources,
such as camera, which
is what I'm doing here.
The two quick snippets that
I showed you earlier on
is part of that
MyCameraRender class, which
I pass on to the
CardSurfaceHolder as a call
back.
If you remember from the
demo, I used Options menu.
But in typical Android world,
you start your own activity
and you draw a menu using it.
But LiveCard is a
remote activity.
The way that this works is that
thankfully, when you initiate
a LiveCard, you can
assign a pending intent.
In my case, I assign an
activity whose sole purpose
is to draw the menu
activity, so that's
when the LiveCard is tapped,
that pending intent gets fired
and my own activity
starts my own menu logic.
To put this demo
into perspective,
all of the other
demos and PY's demo,
it uses the USB port, and
some of Android's default APIs
such as camera and the menu,
and the LiveCard GDK API
to create this Glassware.
I believe that this
setup doesn't stop here,
but it can be used
in other application
domains, such as
medical, as an endoscope,
or for car mechanics-- they can
create a boroscope out of it.
And for a computer vision
people-- folks out here--
can use the second camera to
do their stereoscopic analysis.
The sky's the limit, basically.
In summary, today
we covered some
of the APIs and tools
that are part of the GDK,
and that what we did on
Android to enable all of this.
We showed you two demos
and one existing feature
that explores the
hardware components, GDK
APIs, and Android APIs.
That's it.
Thank you for
coming to our talk.
If you have any questions,
line up behind the microphones.
Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hello, Michael
Prentice from GDG Space Coast.
Last year's demo showed using a
keyboard or other Bluetooth HID
devices.
Right now, that's
not working so well.
Is there any plans
in the immediate time
frame to solve that, and also
support for Bluetooth headset
devices?
HYUNYOUNG SONG: You
want to take this one?
PY LALIGAND: Sure.
Yes, so right now, we're aware
this doesn't work anymore.
I don't if you remember,
but last year, the talk
was Void Your Warranty-- more
of the hacking versions that
came with no guarantee
that stuff would stick.
But actually, we are
obviously interested
in remote peripherals,
especially with Bluetooth.
Functionally, right now
it's not a priority.
When we get done fixing that,
we'll probably fix that.
Same thing with
Bluetooth headsets.
I think that's one of the
top-requested features.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: It's one of
those things that I-- we're
really working hard to
bring it back, as well.
It'll come.
PY LALIGAND: By the way,
there's a work around for this.
If you really need a
keyboard, over ADB,
you can just use the ADB
shell input key event comment.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: 61,
I think, is the path.
PY LALIGAND: Whatever.
It's whatever key code
you can send to the app.
So you don't really
need the keyboard.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: So we'll
take one from the back.
AUDIENCE: Are there
any plans to bring back
Static Card Generation in
the timeline in the GDK.
PY LALIGAND: Not at the moment.
AUDIENCE: OK, I have
one quick question.
Are you guys working
in line with Android
to work with the L release?
With the L release?
HYUNYOUNG SONG: Yes.
I think during the
Wearable Session,
Timothy described
what we're working on,
which is we're already working
with them to bring even
AndroidWear API to Glass so
that from your phone, when
you get a notification,
it doesn't only
send it to your
watch, but also Glass.
A lot of that needs
support from the L release.
AUDIENCE: Mac Coffman, GDG LA.
In the past, there's
been a lot of conflicts
with Google Apps
device policies.
Is that something that's
going to be worked
on making this more
of a corporate tool
than just a personal one?
PY LALIGAND: Yes.
I believe we recently
announced our AdWords program,
and we have a
couple of partners.
I think that's also one of
the top-requested features.
It's still a very
early effort, but I
believe device
admin policies are
among the top things we need
to fix and make work on Glass.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
Also, side question--
did you try two cameras?
HYUNYOUNG SONG: Two cameras?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, with a USB hub.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: I did not.
AUDIENCE: But you
will, I'm sure.
HYUNYOUNG SONG:
Yes, yes, I will.
AUDIENCE: I saw you all recently
added a contextual voice
command, which is really cool.
I was wondering if
you all are going
to expand upon that,
where something
like keyword spotting, where
a user can say something
like Next or Back or something,
and they can navigate the app
without having to change the
UI and actually give them
options to speak.
PY LALIGAND: Just to check,
if I understand correctly--
you would want something where
you don't necessarily have
to say OK, Glass, or
provide a visual cue,
but you just say Next, and--
AUDIENCE: Right.
Very lightweight
keyword spotting
that could navigate
through an application.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: It is
definitely something
that we are--
basically, figuring out
what kind of voice sections are
within regular conversation is
something that we are
actively working on.
There can be a lot
of false positives
to enable this feature.
PY LALIGAND: That's why,
actually, in the first place,
we added that
keyword, OK, Glass.
It's to make sure that
the user intent is clear,
that you want to
issue a command.
Because otherwise this is
super noisy, really noisy.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
HYUNYOUNG SONG:
Gentleman in the back.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I'm interested in
the ScreenCast Viewer
App you are using on your demo.
Do you think you could make this
available to Glass explorers?
It would be really helpful.
PY LALIGAND: OK, we'll take
that request back to the team.
I think it's a fair request.
We're obviously making
heavy use of it,
so let's see what we can do.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: But
for now, there's
an Android screen monitor
that you can download.
PY LALIGAND: I know,
but it's much more
lively than your software.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: Oh, OK.
Future request-- accepted.
PY LALIGAND: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: With USB On the
Go just over the horizon,
are you planning to offer any
other USB devices besides just
the earpiece?
PY LALIGAND: I have no idea.
We're the software people.
AUDIENCE: How about a boom mic?
A boom mic.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: A boom mic.
Yes, that's a great idea.
PY LALIGAND: I don't
even know what that is.
In the back?
AUDIENCE: Could you
provide some timelines
for this L release
support on Glass?
I have had a lot of trouble
making Bluetooth LE totally
work properly.
I'm very much
interested in knowing
when the notifications
will just work, basically.
PY LALIGAND: Well,
actually, they.
It requires some tricky bits.
But, I mean, they work
certainly with that ball.
That really depends
on what device
you're working with, too.
It's fairly tricky.
As for the initial question on
the timeline for the L release,
the short answer is no.
Not because we don't really
want that-- I don't think
we know at this point for sure.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi. [INAUDIBLE].
I just wanted to
hear your thoughts
on-- have you done any video
hardware acceleration using
the H.264 hardware
accelerating Glass?
If so, can you guys provide
examples at some point?
PY LALIGAND: You.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: 264.
I think overall Google
is moving away from 264,
and I believe the latest in
quarter that we have are VP8.
AUDIENCE: Right, but
VP8 isn't hardware--
there's no hardware
accelerator for Glass.
Is there any way to get
a hardware accelerator
video, then, for my Glass unit?
PY LALIGAND: Not that I know of.
For this kind of
stuff, I invite you
to go to the Glass community
and try to get answers there.
Because I know
more people monitor
that than people who
come on stage at I/O.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
PY LALIGAND: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
I may have missed this
in the very beginning
because I was late,
but have you guys
given any kind of time frame for
updating Google Play Services
on Glass to be relatively
standard, and not
for the same API as
it is everywhere else?
PY LALIGAND: That's
also something
for which we have
a lot of requests.
We're working on
it, as something.
We can't really
provide timelines.
I think in general
in the program,
we prefer, in the words
of our software director,
walk the walk,
then talk the talk.
Meaning that we announce
things when they're ready,
and we're not trying
to anticipate too much.
HYUNYOUNG SONG:
All of these things
bring the Default
GestureDetector, Google Play
Services, features that we would
like to have ourselves, too.
One of the priority was--
because bringing up the KitKat
was the utmost priority, we
spent four months upgrading,
and that was a lot of work.
There's a lot of things that
are kind of behind that we want
to get onto as soon as possible.
PY LALIGAND:
Unfortunately, I think
we're running out of time, so
we wanted to thank you again
for coming to our talk.
We'll maybe hang out
little bit outside
if you have more questions.
Thank you.
HYUNYOUNG SONG: Thank you.